moving on to your 20s because this has
been fun your teen years exactly wait I
I really mature a lot throughout
there you go
this is when I moved down on my own okay
is it true that your apartment in
Knocked Up was inspired by your actual
apartment yeah so they were trying to
dress the apartment we all lived in and
knocked up and in the movie it's like
six guys who live together in a
disgusting disaster and they kept like
struggling to dress it right and to make
it look real and so Judd Apatow the
director sent like a like the the
production designer with the camera to
buy house to take pictures and this was
my actual bedroom when I was like 23
years old and we were making knocked up
like while we were shooting off this is
how I lived I love that
to be like
it's probably perfect
Phil's let them go to your house it's
disgusting where you live and I was like
it is pretty disgusting I found that
couch in an Alleyway like uh that's the
futon I grew up in and I changed those
sheets I don't even know if I change
those sheets every once in a while maybe
just like put another sheet over it and
like I think the concept of changing I
didn't even know you had to change
sheets I think and then
um my very forgiving wife I started
dating around this time and she was like
you got to change your sheets man yeah
yeah if you want me in them exactly yeah
she I remember one day she just she was
like yeah it was she told me to clean up
or she was leaving yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody